all right welcome everyone to the second
and hopefully last youtube edition of
itcs
uh my name is ian i'll be talking a
little bit today about lifting theorems
and communication complexity using the
sunflower lemma from combinatorics
so my co-authors on this project are
raghu mecca
japan
and shahar lovett over in california
and then here on the east coast tony
potassi my advisor at university of
toronto who's currently at columbia
so today is going to be a story of two
computation models
decision tree complexity and
communication complexity one weak model
and one strong model so let me introduce
you to them
so decision trees uh capture the natural
notion of adaptive queries
so in adaptive query model
you want to know the value of your
function f on some input z1 up to zn and
the way you're going to do it is you're
just going to ask about successive
variables
so you might first just ask about
the first variable z1
and then based on the answer you get
you might ask for say z3 if you saw a
zero before and ask for a z7 if you saw
one
and anyway as you accrue these answers
you keep asking more and more questions
and eventually you say okay i know the
value of the function
and this is called decision tree because
we can arrange it in a tree like fashion
where each node is labeled with the
variable you query at that step and the
edges are labeled 0 and 1 based on what
you see
so in this model
the decision tree complexity of a
function is the number of queries you
need which is the depth of the
corresponding decision tree
and clearly
decision tree complexity will never be
more than n since uh you can just ask
about all the successive values of the
variables
and
once you have all of them in your hand
you know the value of the function
but it turns out for some very basic
functions like or
this n is tight
so or is a pretty easy example if you
keep asking about variables in any order
and you keep seeing zero then you have
to keep asking because you never know
what the value of the function is until
you've checked every bit
so that's why we call it a weak model
now let's look at our stronger model
communication complexity
so in communication complexity we're not
going to be dealing with one set of
variables the z variables but we're
going to be dealing with two sets of
variables the x variables and the y
variables
and we're going to take each of those
types and we're going to give them to a
different person so alice is going to
get the x variables and bob is going to
get the y variables and what they do
with the variables on their own sides
we're
not going to put any restrictions on it
they want to solve the halting problem
or figure out whether the riemann
hypothesis search is true or false
that's their prerogative
but of course if they want to solve f
they can't do it in isolation because
the other player has the other side of
the input
and so they're going to need to talk to
each other in order to solve the
function and we're going to charge them
for each round that they talk to one
another
so this is going to be communication
complexity and again we can arrange this
in a tree where each node instead of
creating one variable
uh
alice or bob whoever's turn it is to
speak is going to
compute an arbitrary function
over the inputs that they have and based
on the path
in the tree thus far and then again
we'll have edges labeled zero and one
so
once again the communication complexity
will be the depth of this tree
corresponding to the maximum number of
bits sent
and
well for some easy functions like or now
communication complexity does very well
if we just give half the variable if we
give
some of the
variables to alice and some to bob
either one of them can just report what
the or of their variables are and the
other one will know the answer
so
this is maybe not great motivation for
why communication is a strong model
let's see some
more convincing evidence
so if we go back to one party functions
um
f over z one to zn we can define a two
party function called the search uh
problem the canonical search problem
where alice is going to get an input to
f that forces f to output one
and bob is going to get an input f that
forces f to output zero
and since they give different outputs
they clearly can't be the same input and
so they must differ in at least one of
their bits and their only job is to find
a bit where they differ
so this seems like a nice uh
little search problem and you could ask
how hard this thing is
and the answer via karcher and vickerson
is that it's exactly the formula
complexity of your original function f
and by exactly i mean you get the same
tree with the same labels at the leaves
the characterization's really tight
and if you know anything about formulas
you know that proving lower bounds on
the depth of formulas is a really really
hard problem right now the best we've
got is
order log n and not a very big order log
n
so
if we could get stronger lower bounds
via communication complexity this would
be major progress on one of the
long-standing open problems in circuit
complexity
so a reasonably strong model
now what's the connection between these
models besides having this tree-like
structure
well what we have on one hand
is a model that's so weak we can get
lower bounds for it on basic functions
so that's not too interesting and on the
other hand we've got a model that's
strong
enough to uh
you know where lower bounds elude us and
where we really want to prove uh
stronger and stronger lower bounds
and
it would be nice
if we had some way of taking the lower
bounds against the weaker model
uh and transforming the function in such
a way that we could get lower bounds
against the stronger model
so this seems like a lot to ask for uh
when there are such huge gaps between
the complexities of the two functions
but we're going to see some intuition
for why this could uh be the case from
some of the lower bounds we do have for
communication
one of the first lower bounds
anyone learns when they take a
communication complexity course is on
disjointness
so in disjointness alice and bob are
each going to get a set over the
universe of size n
given to them as a
incidence vector
and they want to output one if and only
if there is some element that's in both
of their sets
so what connection does this have to the
or function well in the or function
we've got uh n bits and we want to check
if any of them is one and it's just
jointness we have n elements and we want
to check if any of them overlap is an
overlap point
so if we just look at them in logical
form uh disjointness becomes the same as
the or function but we replace each of
our original variables zi
with a little and over one of alice's
bits x i and one of bob bits then bob's
bits y i
and the lower bound on disjointness the
full uh linear lower bound tells us that
alice and bob can't do that much better
than doing whatever the decision tree
for dead namely queering the bits one in
a row
and
uh communicating in order to find out
the value of the variable uh that
they're querying at any given time
so somehow
the and has obfuscated each of these zi
variables such that we can no longer
express these really interesting
complicated relationships over the zi
variables
in one step we really have to focus on
one zi and solve it in order to know
anything about the top function at which
point uh we're kind of pigeonholed into
or the communication protocol is
pigeonholed into just following say a
decision tree type model
so more generally this gives us the idea
of gadget lifting and gadget lifting is
exactly where we take a one-party
function and turn it into a two-party
function by replacing each variable with
an inner function g which we call the
gadget applied to some fresh set of
variables so zi will be replaced by g of
x i y i
and again we want to pick this gadget g
such that if alice and bob want to know
anything about ci they're basically
going to have to solve j
and
in particular since these inputs are
disjoint we're going to hope that they
basically have to solve the g's one at a
time
so some natural examples
that might help us if we're trying to
obfuscate things maximally would be like
the parity function right so g is x i
parity y i and we're going to see an
even more general gadget which is called
the index gadget
so
the index gadget is going to have some
parameter m and i'm not going to tell
you what m is
just yet
but
fix some m
and then alice is going to get log m
bits which we're going to interpret as a
number from 1 up to m
and bob is going to get m bits which
we're going to interpret as a boolean
array of length m
and
the value of the index gadget is simply
going to be what uh the value in bob's
array is at the location pointed to by
alice's element
uh so this why i'm calling this general
is because uh we could also think of
this as alice getting the input to
a log m bit function and bob having the
truth table of that function
and so
you know we can capture parity or and or
anything else uh as long as we're
willing to let bob have a much larger
gadget on his side
and it turns out that this is general
and obfuscating enough to work so the
grandfather of all lifting theorems is
roz and mckenzie from 1999
which was reinterpreted in 2015 by goose
potassium watson in this lifting
language
and what this result shows is that if
you pick m big enough like polynomial
and n
then the communication complexity of the
lifted function is the decision tree
complexity of the unlifted function
times a log n factor
and the log m factor is what it takes to
solve the index gadget
so to see the easy direction
if we have a decision tree of depth d
solving the unlifted function
then alice and bob can just mimic it by
starting at the top and whenever they
need to query a variable zi
alice sends over all of x i and bob
sends the value of the index gadget
because he now knows where the pointer
is
so in this way they can get a
communication protocol of depth
d times log m plus one
and the other direction is going to be
the harder one and that's what we're
going to talk about today
but first i need to justify why i'm here
you know uh
this is a 20 year old result that has
already been reproven once so so what
are we adding to the table
what we're adding
is
an application of sunflowers a
combinatorial object
in
a central part of the proof and we do
this for three reasons
the first is that
this works for not just this basic
tree-like lifting theorem that i've uh
introduced but also a number of other
lifting theorems that we care about such
as the associated dag-like version
a version where m is made to depend on
the depth of the protocols rather than n
itself
and there are many other lifting
theorems that we care about
and for these three in particular and
quite possibly uh quite likely many
others this sunflower technique we
introduce uh goes through and this is
interesting because all these proofs
actually used different arguments at one
central part of the proof they had some
framing which was
very similar between the different
groups and then they had this central
lemma that they proved in in somewhat
different ways and our proof covers all
of those and not only does it cover all
of those but it drastically simplifies
them
we're going to have
a lemma which is from combinatorics
which is used in sunflowers and that
lemma plus maybe half a page is going to
do most of the heavy lifting that took
pages and pages and previous proofs
so this is a a really nice
simplification and besides these two
quantitative or sorry qualitative
improvements we do have a quantitative
improvement
which is that once you replace
this centerpiece of the proof with our
sunflower technique your gadget size
drops
now when you go to apply lifting
theorems the size of your gadget is
going to play directly into your lower
bound and the larger your gadget the
worse your lower bounds are going to be
so getting m to be as small as possible
maybe one day order one
is very important
and uh previous proofs of lifting
had anywhere from n squared which took a
lot of work to get for the tree leg case
all the way up to n to the 256 which is
still as good as it gets for some of
these proofs and when you replace uh the
old proofs with the sunflower proof
all of the proofs drop all the way down
to uh
almost linear so n to the one plus
epsilon uh for any choice of epsilon or
even n log n if you're willing to
sacrifice a bit in your lower bound
and more importantly
this gadget size is now directly tied to
the sunflower lemma we've removed all
dependence on the gadget size
everywhere except for in this
application of sunflowers
meaning that if we can get further
improvements to the sunflower lemma
something that's been a very uh active
body of research in the past three or
four years
then you're going to get better lifting
theorems as an immediate consequence so
this seems like the most
likely way forward
at the in the current state of affairs
for getting smaller gadgets
all right so that was the preamble and
for the rest of the time i want to
describe at a high level how you prove
these lifting theorems
this is going to cover all uh basically
all the previous proofs and then with
our new sunflower change so hopefully
when this is over you have an idea of
how uh how all of these proofs operate
to some degree
so we're proving the hard direction
which is that we have a communication
protocol which has depth d log m for the
lifted function
and we're going to extract from it a
decision tree
uh for the original unlifted function f
of height only only order d
and to do this i'm going to have to give
you one more view of how communication
protocols operate and if you haven't
seen this before this is the one to
remember if you take communication
complexity this is the one that's most
useful
so
in a one-party function uh the natural
description is a truth table and a truth
table is just a vector of length two to
the n where each entry is indexed by an
input
to the function and the corresponding
value in the vector is the value of the
function
well if you move to a two uh two-party
function then you could just have uh
look at this as a matrix instead where
the rows have alice's side of the input
and the columns have bob's side of the
input and again on entry x y we put the
value of the function f on inputs x and
y
so the useful thing about this is that
if we go back to communication let's say
alice speaks first well we're letting
alice and bob agree on any protocol they
want and computationally unbounded and
such and so really what alice is doing
in the first step
is she's saying which side of a
pre-agreed-upon partition she's on so
they split all of alice's potential
inputs and
into two groups and alice says which
group she's in
and if we look at rectangles this just
corresponds to partitioning the
communication matrix in half
and uh once she once they do this and
she reports which side of the partition
she's on they can actually just toss out
the other half since they've asserted
that they're not in that part of the
communication matrix
and
next say bob speaks and once again
there's a pre-agreed-upon partition and
he says which side he's on they toss out
the other side and they keep going
and once you get to the leaves well
it'd better be the case that they know
the value of the function which means it
better be the case that whatever
rectangle is left over has all the same
entry everywhere and we call this a
monochromatic rectangle
so this is another view of communication
protocols which is uh particularly
useful
all right so keep that in mind we'll
come back to in a second but for now
we're going to get into uh the real
uh the intuition behind the proof
so for starters the whole reason we're
doing this gadget lifting thing is that
our gadget should be obfuscating the
variable zi
and what we mean by that is that alice
and bob need to work in order to get at
any particular input to the unlifted
function
and we're going to say that a coordinate
is important if it looks like they're
spending a lot of communication trying
to figure out the value of a variable
in particular if they spent something
like order log m bits of communication
trying to learn about a particular zi
then first of all this seems like a
coordinate that we should know about and
so it's worth querying the decision tree
and second of all they've spent uh order
log n bits talking about it and in our
goal is to shave a log m factor off of
the height of the communication protocol
so we're happy to query the variable zi
and
you know
we're keeping pace with what the
communication protocol has done thus far
and what's important is that if we
commit to this view of what an important
coordinate is
then the index gadget had better be
doing its job for the rest of the
coordinates in other words if they
haven't spent
something like order log n bits talking
about the variable zi
then they'd better know
nothing about it and remember since the
lifted function
is really f on the outputs of the gadget
these coordinates shouldn't be able to
influence
the output of f
if they're completely free so this is
going to be the dichotomy that we're
going to keep in mind as we decide how
to do our decision tree
now
alice and bob aren't going to declare
what kind of information they're sending
about the variable zi they can send the
parity of
all of their bits and now they're
talking about a little bit about every
uh different coordinate so we need some
way of knowing how much information
they've actually sent
about a coordinate zi and here's where
our rectangle view comes in handy we're
going to say that
the amount that they know about zi
depends on
the x side of the current rectangle so
if we're at rv it's going to depend on
the x side x v when you restrict to the
coordinate i
and we're going to ignore y
we're not going to talk a lot about y in
this talk intuitively
bob's input is so big that it would be
really
it's a waste of their time to send bits
that they aren't sure about and bits
that they're sure about mean that alice
has sent a lot of information about her
pointer so again it's worth focusing on
alice's side
all right so more precisely we're going
to quantify how much we know about the i
variable uh by the entropy of the x set
when you restrict to i so if we fix a
particular assignment
then inside the brackets here we have
the typical entropy expression
for that particular assignment
and we're going to care about the min
entropy which is that we look over all
coordinates i and all assignments to the
possible assignments to those
coordinates alpha i
and we're gonna
minimize the entropy over all those
now entropy if you haven't seen it
before it roughly says
how many bits are still left
indeterminate so in particular if
there's some coordinate i
for which we know exactly what the value
is in the ith coordinate in other words
there's some alpha
such that x sub i a
x is alpha in the i coordinate for all x
in capital x
then our min entropy is going to be zero
and meanwhile if no matter which
coordinate you pick and which assignment
you pick uh you basically you're
basically uniform
then our min entropy is going to be like
log out
again this is like zero bits have been
taken off of the full log m
possibilities for alice's side
and this intuition about it's how many
bits have been uh are still unrevealed
carries over really well in our
rectangle model
if you have a rectangle rv and you
partition it in half say along alice's
side
then what you get is that whichever side
is bigger
actually loses at most one bit of uh min
entropy the min entropy of the smaller
rectangle or of the the larger rectangle
but in the partition
uh
is at least the original min entropy
minus one
and this is great because this means
that it takes you something like omega
log m rounds before uh your min entropy
falls below say one minus order one
falls by an order one times log m factor
and in particular there's going to be
some coordinate i and some assignment
alpha i that witnesses the fact that
your min entropy is less than this
threshold and this tells you exactly
which variable to query in the decision
tree we're going to query zi and we're
going to be happy knowing that it
actually had to spend all of those
rounds
uh dropping
the min entropay
in that coordinate
so
now we want to make sure that uh
whatever rectangle we're maintaining
actually does agree with everything
we've created in the decision tree so
far so if our whole rectangle in from
the communication protocol is rv
and we've got this two likely assignment
x i equals alpha
well we're going to toss out every x
that doesn't agree with that too likely
assignment first
and then we're going to split up on the
y side we're going to split things up
between the y's that give zero on the
index gadget in the eighth coordinate
and the ones that give one
remember that we're fixing one
particular
value for
the i-coordinate on alice's side
and then when we query it in the
decision tree we're just going to throw
out
the wrong answer so if we query the ith
variable and get one we're going to only
keep the part where the index gadget
outputs one and if we get a zero then
we're going to only keep the part where
the index gadget is zero
so that's what's happening in the
important coordinates
and
we need a central lemma to take care of
the unimportant coordinates and what
it's going to say is that as long as you
so we're going to let j be the set of
coordinates that we fixed so far so uh
r j is going to be all the free
coordinates
and our central lemma says that if the
min entropy
of x is high on the unfixed coordinates
over line j
and
y itself stays relatively large
then the index gadget has all the
possibilities available to it and this
isn't just that any
unfixed coordinate has both zero and one
but rather all joint assignments to all
of the unfixed coordinates uh are still
available to us
and so then our central uh subroutine is
going to be that
we have the rectangle rv
associated with the node v in the
communication protocol
and then we're going to be maintaining
our own rectangle inside of it and that
rectangle is going to have all the nice
properties we want for the
coordinates that we've fixed
every entry in r is going to agree with
the value we've fixed uh in the decision
tree so whatever the decision tree says
that zi should be uh our rectangle is
going to agree with that
and then outside those fixed coordinates
the min entropy
of the x side is uh as high as we need
it to be it's like
0.95 log n
and that's going to be for our central
lemma and there's this condition that y
stays large but we won't get into that
today
so this is going to be our main
invariant and again since we're spent
since the communication protocol has to
spend log n bits making a coordinate
important enough to query
then after d log m rounds we will have
queried at most d coordinates in our
decision tree
and so the last thing to do is prove our
uh central lemma
and
this is going to be the more
formal version which is that if the min
entropy of x is at least 0.95 log m uh
minus order one will give it that flex
and uh
the y side starts off
uh as size 2 to the mn because there's
uh
uh ale or bob is going to get n bit
strings of length m
we're going to our largeness condition
on y is going to be that we have at
least a 2 to the minus n log m fraction
of our original size
so if these two conditions hold then not
only is the full out
output range of the index gadget
available
but there's some special row x star in
capital x so that even if we tossed out
everything except for x star we'd still
have everything available to us
so this is actually overkill for uh
proving the central lemma
but uh it has the advantage that it's
not overkill for other proofs like uh
dag-like lifting
and so
this is going to be the form that we
want to prove and it actually is the
form that follows more directly from the
sunflower lemma
and with that it is finally time to
introduce sunflowers
so sunflowers are an object in
combinatorics that appear all over
computer science the new brow actually
just recently wrote a nice survey about
many of the places where sunflowers
appear
and
what a sunflower is is it's a set system
so it's a collection of sets such that
there's some special set called the core
c where all the sets uh intersect in
particular if you picked any two sets in
your set system they would only overlap
in this core they would both contain the
core and they would have no other
overlap
so
pictorially it should be fairly clear
why we call this the sunflower
so these were introduced in the 60s by
erdogan rado
and what they cared about was certifying
that a larger set system has a sunflower
inside of it
they showed that if all of your sets
have size at most d
and your whole set system has size at
least d factorial times k to the day in
other words if it's sufficiently large
then
there is a sunflower inside it and that
sunflower has uh k sets in it so
you can pick k to be whatever you want
and as long as your set system is
appropriately large you can find a
sunflower of that size in there
and follow-up work on the sunflower
lemma has focused on improving
the requirements on the size of your set
system
so
the ultimate goal is to remove any
dependence from d
on d from the base
and
our first real improvement like a
substantive improvement
in about 60 years
was this result by always at all who
showed that the base can be reduced to k
log dk
this was a huge result and uh i hope
that there's a lot of follow-up work
that comes out in the next few years
sunflowers really deserve
quite a bit of more attention than they
even currently get
but while we're not going to go into the
always at all proof uh we're going to
isolate this one lemma
which says that
uh in our translated to our language
if f has sufficiently large block-wise
min entropy where sufficiently large is
basically log log n over epsilon for a
universe of size n
then
if you pick a random set of the whole
universe the probability that that set
doesn't contain
any of the sets in your set system f is
at most the epsilon that you chose
so this relates to sunflowers because
this is connected to an approximate
notion of sunflowers uh but we're gonna
use this lemma straight out of the box
and from here our proof is uh pretty
straightforward so we're gonna assume
for contradiction that there's no
special x star that gives the full range
of the index gadget and so in particular
for any x you pick
there's a bad assignment beta x which is
not in the output of the index gadget
when you restrict to x
and the worst case is going to turn out
to be when beta x is the all ones
assignment
uh you'll have to read the paper to
understand what i mean by worst case
and
we're going to now transition to a set
view
of x and y
so our universe is going to be mn
and x each x in capital x is going to be
a set
of size n
remember that there are n coordinates in
x and each of them is a pointer from 1
to m so this defines a set in mn of size
n in the natural way
and our block wise min entropy condition
on capital x
we're going to
assert that this actually is good enough
for the sunflower lemon that we were
using
so in particular we're going to pick
epsilon to be 2 to the minus n log m
and we want that our block wiseman
entropy is at least
like roughly log log m n uh over epsilon
m n is the size of our universe remember
and i want to point out here that this
is the one place where we have to
uh
fix the gadget size so we need for this
condition to hold we're going to need to
pick m to be something like n to the 1.1
and it's pretty clear since we picked
0.95 arbitrarily you can make this n to
the one plus epsilon by adjusting the
parameters accordingly
so anyway once we fix m to be
sufficiently large then we have the
conditions for our sunflower lemma and
so
we know that if you pick a random
set over the universe m n the
probability that none of our uh sets x
is contained in this random set is at
most the epsilon we picked two to the
minus n log n
and just moving to an incidence vector
view of these things
uh if you pick a random bit string of
length mn and we view it as
a set where the ones are the elements
included
then it says that
for any x you pick the probability that
uh
that y
does not uh does not equal the all ones
vector when you restrict to the spots
indicated by x the probability that that
doesn't hold for all x is at most
epsilon as well
uh this is the same line moved up
and now if we just look this up look at
this as the set of vectors fulfilling
this condition we know that that set has
size at most uh 2 to the mn is all
possibilities minus n log m which is
less than the size of y
and what this means is that there's some
y in capital y which doesn't fulfill
these conditions and
you can show
very straightforwardly then that uh it
means that the index gadget actually
does output the assignment that we
claimed wasn't there
even uh even restricted to little x
so
this is the end of the proof of our main
lemma and the end of our uh lifting
theorem
so before i go i just want to mention a
couple things to think about going
forward
the first is that
uh while we
for we're the first ones to show that
better sunflowers imply better lifting
there's actually already a result that
shows that better lifting implies better
sunflowers
and so it'd be nice now that we have
this bi-directional implication
to develop kind of more
uh a deeper connection between
sunflowers and lifting maybe
some syntactic equivalence between them
instead of just approving these two
separate directions
and then for more straightforward open
problems the main one of course is to
reduce the gadget size further so we
have n to the one plus epsilon it'd be
good to get it to n it would be good to
get it sub linear and it would be
fantastic
to get it a constant size this would
have many many implications
throughout complexity theory
and
if you
think that this might be a little tricky
a little too tricky then um
i would suggest looking at other gadgets
besides the index gadget so the inner
product gadget is one that's been
studied quite a bit but for which we
only know
some of the results that we know for
index gadget and if you can make our
proof technique work in the uh for the
inner product gadget say then this would
imply immediately the rest of the
lifting theorems that we care about and
that would have further implications as
well
so that's it and i just want to make a
quick plug which is if you want a more
technical uh in-depth version of this
talk i
gave it's uh recorded on youtube for the
meow research seminar so i suggest you
check that out
or of course feel free to read the paper
but anyway that's it uh thank you so
much and i will see you at the
virtual session